this is what we call in the booking
business stepping in it we were just
going to preview the season but we now
we now have a man who's been all over
this story for the athletic senior nba
writer for the athletic same hammock sam
amick here on the richison show how are
you sam
really good rich thanks for having me
brother oh no i appreciate it are you
regretting accepting my invitation right
now because your phone's blowing up with
information
it's been a morning it's funny we'll get
into the sim and stuff i've actually i
got a story coming out a little bit
talking to james jones the uh the sun gm
about that the deandre eight and stuff
which is a pretty
compelling one on its own so that has
been my morning trying to get that thing
out and then i look at twitter and i see
ben uh like you just kind of detailed
getting getting
the old heave-ho old school style like
like it's a high school team or
something
um so yeah it's just the latest turn in
the finish saga here okay so let's take
it one at a time starting with what
everybody's talking about right now
what can you tell me about what happened
today best you can tell and and how your
reporting leading up to this kind of
framed
the moment sam so i mean today seems
pretty straightforward doc rivers has
already spoken on it and you know it's
just a player who
wasn't following commands if you will
at practice and who chose not to sub in
uh for a particular drill and was then
deemed a distraction i mean it's not
surprising at all to see it go down this
road you know because it's 2021 the the
the i think jarring part is just
that we have a window into their world
you know what i mean you've got these
videos of of the phone in the pocket and
things of that nature but if you
remember a few weeks ago
you know and this is stuff like you
alluded to that i had written at the
time
um you know his camp and his side and
his people
said all along like if he comes back
he will not be there mentally like his
body might be there his spirit will not
he is mentally checked out on the sixers
now admittedly you know that's at the
time i thought all right that's easy to
say now but ben is not really considered
personality wise you know a jimmy butler
type or even an anthony davis type so
people wondered you know did he kind of
have
the thick skin to carry himself in this
kind of defiant way and and obviously he
he is going down that road so pretty you
know pretty uncomfortable right now so
um
what are the sixers options here they've
just suspended him one game for conduct
detrimental but that's a road
opener against the pelicans
which means he's eligible to return for
oh wait a minute the home opener against
the nets and this is the
the setup for what they're gonna they're
gonna introduce him with the spotlight
to the crowd and now put your hands
together like really i mean what what's
the options here what are the moves for
the sixers i mean it seems you know and
i haven't connected with them since this
latest development but
it seems untenable to me and it seems
headed
toward a
you know you know essentially kind of a
declaration of all right why don't you
go ahead and stay home and we'll keep
working the trade market now that's not
what they wanted you know daryl morris
their their sixer president was the one
who had brought up you know the the kind
of
uh somewhat um you know overly hopeful i
guess i'll say aaron rodgers example
like oh just like the packers qb came
back to his group and started leading
them to wins maybe ben would do that
ben's obviously not going to do that and
you know they hoped that he would get on
the floor and remind the rest of the nba
how good of a player he is up his trade
value and then get something you know um
that was more amenable to what they want
to do trade wise but i just don't see
that happening you know and i don't know
what they're going to do but we have
seen in other situations you know the
timberwolves on the back end of their
jimmy butler experience would certainly
tell you
that they made a mistake in having him
come back that they should have just
told jimmy to stay home that it creates
too much of a distraction you have a
ripple effect on your teammates on staff
members it just makes everybody
miserable and again we're seeing that
right now well i mean the difference sam
amick of the athletic senior nba writer
here on the rich eisen show the
difference between aaron rodgers and ben
simmons
um
just glaring would be your story um
about what simmons thought apparently
about um joel embiid's
presence in the paint and how that's a
detriment to his game it's never
when aaron rodgers was thinking about
not coming back he was never quoted as
saying devonte adams was a problem you
know like so
just putting it all back together again
figuring let's just all try it and hope
that simmons will show up like aaron
rodgers and just go through it
i i you know that that might be a little
bit pie in the sky so what what now can
they send him home can they can they
basically say
you're not coming and that's it and the
nba players association the nba pa is
going to be just fine with that that's
called the discussion that no i mean at
that point it's our you know is he
getting paid or not and so then that
that i keep using that word
uncomfortable that's where it's you know
if you're banned it's like man are you
really going to do this are you really
going to
walk you know kind of do this high wire
act where you decide how little energy
do i need to put forth in order to
continue getting paid while also sending
the message that you know i'm still
upset with you i don't want to be here i
want you to trade me you know that's a
pretty impossible
needle to thread in my opinion because
he's already made it clear
not surprisingly that he wants to get
paid when he started losing money that's
when he came back it was getting close
to about a million dollars that that he
had already lost and so you know voila
ben simmons is back so i mean yes they
can sideline him but then the discussion
about pay is one that the union is going
to be heavily involved in um and i agree
with you completely about the aaron
rodgers comparison where it falls short
because
you know he has not only done being in
philly and he kind of
refutes the idea that the fans play a
part here but you know come on you can't
tell me i mean that's a tough crowd
they haven't been happy with them that
doesn't make it any easier but yeah he
wants them to build around joel embiid
go on their merry way and put him in a
new spot so what is the trade market for
him best you can tell sam what is it i'm
not
yeah i mean i you know every team that i
run into
um
it's just red flags galore and not what
struck me a little bit
is that it it does extend i think beyond
you know what has taken place this
season i think you know the book on ben
if you will
you know even before this there you know
because of the shooting and the lack of
development on that side there were
questions about um you know call it work
ethic call it just you know dedication
to the development side and that stuff
is pretty glaring obviously you know
there's questions about
fit personality wise i just i think
teams have concerns but then of course
they look at it and go all right guy was
second and defensive player of the year
voting last season even when he
struggles offensively he's a game
changer on the other end so i mean the
market is there
the timberwolves have been
the most aggressive to this point even
through their front office change that
took place recently um you know we've
heard other teams involved that kyrie
irving prospect i was told is definitely
not something that that philly has
interest in in terms of both those teams
solving their problems so i don't know
where this goes still because the market
is
nowhere near what daryl moore wants it
to be i'm sorry i should have re let me
free phrase the question how does rich
paul get simmons to the lakers how does
that happen i should have i should have
asked that way my bad
how does that happen ben that's a good
question
you know
yeah rush in a philly jersey russian
embiid i don't know can you flip them
that quick i don't think they're allowed
to do that um yeah it's a rock and a
hard place man like and rich you know i
mean listen rich is obviously a big
character in this situation and rich was
at the center of the anthony davis
situation when anthony pushed his way
to laker land um you know and and that
one he got what he wanted this one is
different in terms of ben does not have
a target team that he's trying to go
after um it's more so just get me out of
philly and get me somewhere you know
where i can i can have a new chapter a
few more minutes left with sam emic of
the athletic senior nba writer art you
came on the air and said that you've
been tracking down uh deandre ayton's
contract saga in phoenix um prior to
everything blowing up in sixers practice
what is the latest um in phoenix with
that well i'll have probably in fairly
short order we're going to publish an
interview with sons gm james jones
talked at length about
why they chose not to give deandre the
max deal that he wanted and that he
thinks he deserved and
it's i mean honestly rich it's um
it's a good old-fashioned you know parts
of it anyway or he said he said
uh you know i did talk to deandre's
representatives
um
you know and they're not pleased at all
with
the characterization
uh from the suns and james of how this
went down you know james feels like
there was not a an actual negotiation
that they
claimed that they would have been open
to discussing
three-year max deals four-year max deals
and you know and deandre's people are
100
basically calling bs on that and saying
that's just not how this went down so
you know for a team that it was a pretty
neat story getting to the finals
unexpectedly and things being fantastic
in the valley of the sun just a couple
months ago you know this is not how they
want to go into this year no absolutely
and i don't want you to give up too much
of what people should go
uh get the app go however you want to
read um sam's work on the athletic i
don't want to take up too much of you
cannibalizing your your post that's
about to come but
what you know why why not
i mean
you know like like what what would be
the issue of just giving the kid what he
wants because we saw even when chris
paul was uh doing what his his stuff and
you know and devon booker was doing his
stuff uh that they still needed ayton's
presence in a significant way that he
was a difference maker even though this
is such an outside
uh game in now in the nba that that he
has some serious value to that team at
his position athletically and so much
earlier yeah no question and more
importantly in terms of the business
side you know most executives are
handicapping that he'll have no problem
getting max money next summer so he'll
be a restricted free agent they of
course can match next summer my general
sense to your question rich is that i
think robert sarber
would just prefer to deal with this next
summer and would prefer to not be
you know kind of saddled with a
five-year max that that's clearly what
they didn't want now and this is again
in the column but there's some
discussion about you know in the nba in
the way the cba operates you can only
have two designated rookie max
extensions per team and devin booker
already had one so there's a little bit
of a sense from
james's side that you know if if we
would have given deandre that second one
then if we wanted to chase
another star player that was also on a
designated rookie max that that would
limit some of their ability to
potentially add star power there is some
logic there but like i write it is it's
you know it's pretty far-fetched to
think about getting a guy like that
without giving up a booker or an ayton
type so
um i think at base level sarver in my
opinion preferred to kick the can to
next summer uh didn't want the five-year
deal would rather
ultimately match a four-year deal but
the human component is always you know
maybe gonna nip you in the bud because
you if you offend your guy and he
doesn't want to be there anymore if you
know and i'm not saying that's the case
he has not asked for a trade you know
that's not happening by any means but
you know the human component matters and
right now it's not in a great place yeah
i guess leave it in monty williams hands
to fix it right in the locker room and
in the huddle and and what have you um
okay last one for you sam uh sam emic or
the athletic what's the what's the
overarching storyline coming into
this season is it will kyrie take the
shot uh can the lakers uh do it with
russell westbrook and a.d and lebron i
mean
uh what do you got for me on uh the
tip-off to the 75th diamond season
well in the interest of of just being uh
coben fatigued in terms of that being
part of the sports discussion right i'm
gonna i'm gonna skip over the kyrie one
that's obviously a massive story though
i'm in la right now i
will be at lakers warriors tonight i
have lakers on the mind i went to lakers
practice yesterday talked to lebron
talked to frank mogul a little bit and
the russell westbrook story to me is you
know if nothing else it's going to be
must-see tv it's going to be really
interesting you know he's
last couple years russ has gone from
let me make it work with james harden
let me try to play off the ball
not be the alpha male okay this is not
working like i thought it would now i
want to go to washington and play by
russell westbrook brand of basketball
again you know i'm gonna break oscar
robertson's triple double record it's
going to be that brand of russell
westbrook basketball and then you know
lo and behold now i'd say i want to get
home and play in la and it's closer to
that houston formula that he tried
unsuccessfully to figure out before so
and probably even tougher you know to
integrate him
with lebron and ad from a functionality
standpoint so i'm dying to see if it
works um i think you know it's
we've seen this before super teams that
didn't work um you know dwight howard
steve nash kobe bryant come to mind in
2012 with pal gasol we saw how that
ended so i don't know if this is going
to be this team's story or if it's going
to you know be something grander but i
think that one's a big one and what a
team to be facing against the warriors
right klay thompson's return
and so much more i mean like that is
something for sure that you're
that that'll be an interesting aspect to
tonight's game as well i can't wait to
see that i mean that one to me rich is
going to be really interesting on the
back end of the season when they get
klay thompson back hopefully around
december january you know how dangerous
can they be if if things fall the right
way for them yeah i can't wait to see
all of it uh sam um really appreciate it
i know your phone's blowing up you got
some stuff to do but one last thing if
you don't mind adding to your to-do list
today of what to track down if you don't
mind i'll be your editor for a split
second but this is why i do this and not
really editing can you find out where
ben simmons got those sweatpants
i am
fascinated by them they seem to be just
standard run-of-the-mill gray sweatpants
i don't know i'm not a fashion guy
but they don't seem to be team issued
like the sweatpants you know i think
that just it's obviously it's an apple
phone that's in the pocket sure sure but
i i don't know rich if we have a we
might have a mutual friend here our
colleague chris mannix is sports
illustrated
those those sweatpants look really
similar to the pear that chris wore for
six consecutive weeks in the bubble
um and that you know that it smelled in
ways that clothes should never smell so
i don't know maybe maybe mannix let then
borrow his weapon well you know what um
uh sam i can't believe you're letting
mannix get that scoop but um you know i
understand you got other things and
other fish to fry but i i'm just
fascinated i mean because again we
played the old seinfeld line like you
know sweatpants are just like he told
george it's like i've given up it's it's
i'm i'm unhappy but at least i'm going
to be comfortable like literally that's
what he's that's what he gives off today
it was a seinfeld episode you know 100
you know some publicist somewhere was
was calling those strings and saying
these are the optics we need
sam appreciate the time thanks for
calling let's look for my call again
thank you that's one of the best senior
nba writer from the athletic sam amick
he's in the downtown hooves dojo tonight
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here